welcome to this video round six of tata
steel 2013 and again i'll do a complete
round review seven games and add some
remarks about the first couple of videos
about them the order in which i do the
games some people suggested that I
should do the most interesting games
first and do the somewhat less exciting
at the end I'm really not sure how to
how to do that what I'm going to do is I
start with the less interesting but do
them very quickly and then go to the to
the real main parts of of this round
okay let's start with them the game like
hammer against la même we had talked on
defense until like I'm we're playing a
did once so very standard moves night c8
it's not so standard time I'm not sure
if this is a new idea like an
immediately get this night out of the
way and we pass Bishop e7 and castling
and sometimes this night can be
redeployed on b6 so it's not such a bad
post at the moment and then fact that we
see that why does trying to get some
play in the center will see form couple
of moves later can white exchange this
bishop and now we have an interesting
transformation black top with the eft on
which some for some people might look a
bit weird as you are taught to cap
capture towards the center here son
no exception f KX g 6 is far stronger
than the h-bomb we captured the problem
is if you take with the H porn then can
put it on the board long-term you can
get some problems on the King side with
various attacking ideas 1 is 2 for y to
get the Queen all the way over to the H
file and then put something on G 595
threatening mate and this can can be
tricky because with this pawn formation
you can never move one of those pawns
you move the f porn that is 6 will get
terminally week and the other big issue
is h4 h5 in the game after the f1
recapture you notice that immediately
this rook gets played h4 h5 is not such
a big deal you can just take it and
there's no point H file and white also
um cannot easily attack h7 because black
can also set up in this fashion so ft x
36 is much stronger in fact this whole
formation that we get here this is very
similar to a pawn structure that usually
rise in the slaf main line with the
details see for a for Bishop f5 and
quite funny this kind of structural
transposition the thing is so black is
very very solid he's got good pieces
from from a strategic point of view good
bishop p.m. the only issue is the nights
are somewhat awful but he gets to
coordinate them it takes some time while
he got rid of his Bishop and black
immediately starts to regroup the
Knights and once it arrives on c6 then
Black has solved lots of his problem
simply because this night blocks the C
file so there's no invasion on g7 or
something the night also text before
which is wise weakness
and I think white is it's just an equal
position we see some further maneuvering
but there's frankly not much happening
get one pair of rooks exchange and white
goes to g6 but there's no threat ready
it's just one Queen yeah some further
regrouping um problems here's some yam
how do you make progress and this one is
actually an applicable for both sides
here black doesn't have any porn break
he simply cannot open up the position or
change the pawn structure in any way but
he's of course very solid with this rook
on the ave albany far and wide only has
got one break also which is at four yeah
maybe h forward to toast the f4 f4 is
hard to play with the rook on a fade so
we see in the game that in the camera
actually manages so to get f4 in but
it's not not doing so much gentium draw
was agreed and dumb this shows that is
probably really nothing to play for if a
fight Alana camera offers a draw then
there is nothing um like has all kinds
of possibilities you can go to young
maybe here and check the spawn white
king is also somewhat exposed you cannot
easily open up further and we let's just
for instance if white would play at five
going going going active then then at
the end there's this Queenie one check
which is very annoying could even argue
that like is somewhat more comfortable
in this position
yeah maybe black girl what happens after
9f g6 like has some pressure on this
phones what do not so clear what why
should do they are also positional ideas
like this locating at five yeah black is
certainly fine maybe you should have
played on even yeah sometimes it's
difficult if you have them somewhat the
position like this where you just sit
and wait as black against the stronger
play and then you get to draw for you
often just take it and don't think about
the implications of the position maybe
black is even better here all right but
all in all not too exciting this game
and even though less exciting was the
game Caruana against Kuryakin
unfortunately we have the Berlin again
which is really am yeah I understand why
those players would go for this line but
from spectators point of view it's it's
really nothing nothing great to him to
to watch and do to to do them to do any
comments on ok so we have this famous
Berlin Wall end game but Black now has a
ton of moves we should be seven h6 all
kinds of moves yeah kini eight is the
old one on the oldest one h5 this idea
is relatively new to play em to play
this point to move h6 is also move yeah
this is very fairly 1x explored this
opening nowadays what we can see in fact
I'm looking look at this I was thinking
about this position this is what I saw
during the broadcast this is a very
typical structure for this opening and
in fact I don't see em at all what white
this is trying to do here like somebody
has got a perfect blockade set up with
night f5 and don't want to H form and
this is really am some kind of duel is
meant for this h5 block blend it really
kills off all that the writer might do
and I really don't see what what why
should should try to do to make any kind
of progress yeah this was simply taken
yeah and now like has pretty nice night
irani six sitting there covering c7 and
sort of yep locating the upon some not a
classic blockade because it's not an ass
bone but it's sitting very nicely in
front of the porn and now I'm a typical
and then good maneuver night route to
age five this is simply directed against
FYI five white would play a four then
like can't even think about this move
alternatively go here and now the rook
and the night both prevent the f porn
from from further advancing very typical
maneuver and like even manages to look
at this rank very cute matches to get
both ropes on the fifth rank and detect
the e porn yeah whiter needs to protect
it and now like justice it in the wait
I'm not quite sure how many moves they
made until they did we change oops there
was even something happening I was I
wasn't even aware of that I thought it
was just a completely uneventful draw
sorry 98 and white took here uh-huh
okay okay let's see what happens can't
shoot 500k black of course cannot go
back checkmate mate still wins even in
such a doll position okay so Janet went
here take stakes are interesting check
before I cool move Black has gotten the
activity with the King so wide I cannot
exchange here comes after this it's a
problem likes king is immediately
threatening and if white tries to keep
the ball then at the end like them like
is the one on you have trying to win
maybe maybe it's the wrong hard to
figure out yeah and then the thing is
just from a practical point of view if
you're wide young and the opponent plays
route before you notice a few exchange
rooks that you are in some kind of
trouble and the pond and can easily can
be lost yeah it's not like you we have a
draw in hand or something you can easily
lose it so I wouldn't recommend to
exchange looks if you have relatively
easy yeah rook endgame that you can draw
and in fact them blacks simply needs to
attend those two pawns and white just
perpetually attacked them and draw was
agreed this is just a much better
decision from my spawn if you instead of
taking even if if it is some kind of
false drawer you don't really want to
allow this okay pretty uneventful
unfortunately in this opening the Sun
happens rather often okay next game
harikrishna against island
the Indian duel entire Krishna playing
Knight f3 after this very sharp and
interesting attacking game against when
valley with you for he returns to Knight
f3 and in place g three years so the
yeah some sort of from Reggie opening
yeah now we have a real reti opening
yeah i played this opening myself as
wide so i know a bit of about all this
like set up what what Alan plate he is a
very solid of cause it's kind of a
London system with the worst colors and
this is known for its s solid reputation
of course yeah queen bee three is some
good good idea to try to make some
progress Queen B 6 and yeah I don't
really like him how harikrishna is now
continuing um he played them 94 which is
so yeah somewhat tricky of course
because like I would take then white can
simply take the end and win instantly so
one light is not there not blundered um
and it detects so the bishop oops six
and 94 yeah it detects the bishop prone
to friends to demolish the pawn
structure so black needs to react in
fact I what I like more in this position
is the move Bishop to e3 um I think that
white has still hopes for I'm trying for
a very small advantage after the smooth
the idea is that ok the queen is simply
attacked and and it needs to be a
exchanged on b3 and now watch got the
half open a file which means them that a
seven is hanging and black probably
needs to go a six at some point and in
this position white can try for for a
little bit of something like this kind
of stuff
going going whoops going on those
sensitive squares another idea is to
exchange on d5 and try you for opening
up the position it's not the spectacular
game coming up obviously but I think
white can can try for for a bit without
risking anything the end the game a 94
was played and machine we treated the
bishop and now we have exchanging on d5
and white now actually played the Queen
exchange which basically admits that
you've got nothing um typically the site
who exchanges queens and gift the
opponent the double porn is the one yeah
getting into the yag entity getting onto
the defensive so white in this case the
double porn is usually an advantage for
the side was gathered because the rook
is open instantly and the double pawn
can be very useful yet you can advance
it and play on the queenside without
moving the original be pawn which is
used to set up this strong confirmation
against the bishop on the diagonal so
very often this double bonus an
advantage even so one yeah what Anna did
is very slowly increasing crash on the
queenside see what happened the beep on
March let you why this place in the
night yeah black got them the slight
advantage share it's not spectacular but
it so it is slightly better simply with
them space advantage and white having
somewhat awkward pieces
yeah trying to regroup the night on the
way to deform and in fact couple of
moves later yeah one of them takes more
space while the item cannot do much note
that the rooks and lastly protecting the
B point from the side and the rukon a7
combined with the bishop has got some
pressure on the a pond yeah with this
idea try to use the pawns yes I'm still
black a somewhat better it's not so easy
to tell in fact if you look at the
continuation here how how black sport is
advantage 94 some for once an active
move giving up the protection of the a
porn and initiating a longer tactical
sequence or let's say forced somewhere
for sequence I don't know decided to
take the pawn which was haunted with 93
and the idea was that 95 has a threat
and also d-force a threat and this is
the more important thread because then
we seven would would hang which you know
played rugby seven and the mansion
deform yeah if black now I would play
let's say 94 then why'd would take and
even have an advantage she got the porn
back end there's 95 or 93 to e5 coming
so this is not good at all but black has
a good response and i played this f4
using this strong bishop so instead of
doing a retreat and giving up the ponies
playing active moves yet white LED g4
just probably the best now black has two
nights attacked but of course the
exchanges saying and Anna took it and
why just recaptured and we'll get one of
the one of the nights and yet certainly
make sense to to play em in a way that
this night is given up as it doesn't
look too great on age five I'll are now
played 94 and this is interesting but he
also had a pretty a good alternative in
night to e6 the idea is quite quite
interesting if white would take now then
black has the interesting option to
sacrifice on f3 the exchange like white
recaptures and now not deform and in
this position black has got those three
pawns for the piece of course oky just
got four against three on the King side
but this paw information is really sick
and I think this is interesting because
then it still should offer black some
chance to play for win and it's still
very risk free way to to play I mean how
should black ever lose this position
probably will get even the f3 porn so
this was an interesting way to play in
the game as much to play tonight to e4
takes and now Knight f6 going against
the poem and grabbing it there was also
Knight c3 and also rook takes f3 again
this IDM um but this was was also an
interesting way to play
taking the rook be two for instance rook
a1 and Roxy tune and now from may be
here yeah it's it's all these positions
look somewhat slightly better for black
but it's not like black ism winning
instantly why it still has some yeah
some solid set up here the night years
hard to to get rid of okay with an
exchange sake but not with normal means
and it's protected this is also nicely
protected so black a certain is somewhat
better but maybe it's nothing nothing
too special yeah in the game he went
back and we see that age for now led to
two simplifications and here after this
in fact after okay for the game was a
breach drawn I actually think that maybe
blackham could have played on a bit I'm
not sure I mean black is not risking
anything and he could could maybe play a
play a couple of more moves maybe it's
not not too great but why not continue
forward and let's fall and say for
instance well here's here draw was a bit
but let's say III for example and yeah
black hood um maybe take here and then
try to use the pawn I'm sure if you
should do it instantly if I play this
white handsome as it quite nicely
blocked but maybe at some later stage
this is the general idea maybe
and activate the king and you could try
on a bit White has got the Jeep on so
it's it's probably it's probably still
balanced the computer always it's all
about 000 here or very low I'm evil yeah
okay maybe they could have played on but
it's not very likely that it would be
something else than a draw alright so I
still managed to do 20 minutes of not so
exciting games canter myself there's the
content in those games okay so now for
the decisive games and let's start with
the van Valley against warhol and quite
surprisingly one who plays the Kings
Indian um he doesn't play this often I
think he goes for I'm very rare line
which is some not regarded so well by
theory not like it's bad or something
but it's not one of the main lines that
like place they did the idea is to go
night before and simplify am a bit so
let's say something like this it's
actually pretty solid for black the idea
can be to even play d5 later exchange
here playy six and black is really rock
solid everything on white squares good
bishop and gap it's it's very solid more
like a sloth dinner then a kinks in yet
um okay why played night you one here
which is probably the better move in
terms of getting something going on the
center white intends to play you for
takes you foreigner control and so we
see that this happens like matches to
exchange this bishop
and all this looks fairly standard but
now okay now here here I'm very early on
we get a critical moment in the game um
probably black here should play some
some some slow moves that doesn't really
change the position too much I'm not
quite sure what move something like this
maybe on 96 or something some sit and
wait move from why does certainly
slightly better I mean he's got the
typical space advantage and um it's not
them like like is close to breaking with
f5 and getting some attack in the game
we played b5 and them while this may be
it is still okay but it's really risky
why it took now this so I'm yeah black
has sacrifice upon and the idea actually
must be to to get this pawn back and
have the central pawns d anyporn in fact
in the game he never managed to get this
spawn back and this really turned into a
big problem played the Quincy form
rookie one yeah now black cannot take
because of this ball this move and with
the rook hanging you can't unique state
change and yeah this is just a
completely winning endgame it's not just
the extra point it's it's simply too
much white will push those phones and
promote on the queenside
this is why black cannot take now and
played some slow move age six and yeah
it's still the same you cannot take and
white simply pushes the pawns and also
has got a g5 he wants to get some
activity going but it really doesn't
manage what even could complain i th
five now if you went a bouquet for which
was one idea about this a pawn push
driving the Queen back and now I'd went
back to it too and this opens up this
great route and here white is probably
winning with with good play it's an
extra porn it's the potential passport
and this idea with the planning the
knight on c6 why black has basically no
play see these moves and the night is on
the way to c6 ok some prophylaxis first
yeah some shuffling to gain some time on
the clock and now black played nada 3m
and after this it's it's really
completely over could could try
something else like like this again but
white can can play Nancy succeed simply
took his time with this move but he can
play this now and it's just very close
to winning with this big advantage on
the queenside after Knight f3 in fact we
are white also went here and the nidus
is simply somewhat worse on f3 then I'm
d3 black white here
yeah towards the King may be trying to
get some some last shot at the King so
we are whiter Scott got a very strong
best porn and just pushes a check night
like Wiener three check young and dumb
if like him would them try to run yeah
the problem would what I'm getting at is
white is threatening v8 Queen if black
would do some some nothing move let's
say back to f3 yeah just for argument's
sake then white wood to promote check
and play this move this is what I was
getting at so this is also my moves the
Queen but still what do you do about the
B porn yeah just good technical play F
bone is protected and white would love
to exchange queens of course and then
just promote to be born check like
exchanged and grab this but now why it
has got 93 with tempo and on f5 there's
a great square yeah the beep all in
combination with the g 5y five squares
too much here we go black ass sighs no
defense IAM also d successor is simply
hanging
try to be eight but after the capture on
g7 now um yeah black black reside
problem is what what should he do he
would recapture with the king then
there's just bishops III winning this
yeah in exchange and with interest and
get this has got two pieces hanging so
black loses a piece with the no
compensation whatsoever yeah to be
honest I think this was an opening
disaster he really never got got
anything for for this pawn and yeah
maybe there's some precise way to get 25
but I'm not sure how how how you should
do it and then let the Queen side is
simply so are in such a bad shape that
you cannot recover this simply it looks
looks terrible for black yeah good win
for FN really also he managed to win the
second game he won against la me earlier
and now he's on fifty percent which is a
really good term against this field so
I'm really recovered nicely um yeah he
lost her very badly to cards and what
you want two games afterwards great okay
so this was a good win for him and now
have a look at Aronian against alaikum
this was unfortunately a very long game
and i only am will show a couple of key
moments the Queen's Indian and Romeo
plays this very sharp pawn sacrifice
black and one the d5 pawn and white
sacrifice it it's not a blunder and the
idea is that black yeah needed to invest
some time to get the porn and in fact
his central confirmation is not so great
as the deponent is backwards and
can very often gain more time on this
night for example let's let's just have
a look what what happened yeah this is
quite cute this night is not hanging if
why would take now then not before what
would win this rook with the fork so the
Queen moves again to attack the night it
retreats and now we see that white gets
this move in and prevents black from
advancing the deep one yeah II five and
yeah it's um it's quite believable that
white has decent compensation you've got
this pawn guaranteeing you a space
advantage and black ass all kinds of
holes in the position so what certainly
has compensation we see that yeah this
was erroneous idea yeah we see this move
which is interesting hmm lekha wants to
get rid of this bind and gives up a pawn
for this so I'm sorry so we have this
exchange and now the technical shot
night xt5 exchanging more pieces even
know why took here he would catch on on
b7 link can take here and you're you're
in a self pinned with Bishop takes b7 um
it's really a not great for white if you
would recapture then group takes b7 it's
probably even somewhat better for black
if you count the pawns it's the one on
up so this is just better which takes
and Queen d7 near now we see that the
Queen exchange Queen trade is some
unavoidable and white has got the
slightly better pawn structure those two
pawns a week but of course
compensation black has got two bishops
he secured this Bishop by dropping it
back all the way yeah so this sir is
what i meant in some night and bishop
against two bishops but some weaknesses
public and in fact ready here lako
played f6 night moves and now we play
droop the eight which is really am
remarkable decision it's um it's a
fairly typical decision for for
top-level chess nowadays but it's um sir
move that I probably wouldn't play okay
I'm not top level chasm like those guys
but I wouldn't play this move anyway and
what I'm getting at is rook t8 what did
what he did huh I'm sorry rook e8 what
he did in fact white just chill on the
spawn and of course hehe did see it he
didn't blunder this born and so the idea
was to give up the week porn to get him
an endgame with the two bishops as
compensation for the porn um and black
has slight compensation for the pawn to
Bishop saw a nice but still I'm really
surprised why why why did that because
white doesn't really threaten anything
here I mean black can easily play move
like Bishop c6 and I don't really see
how whiter could get something great
going here as long as the rooks on
there's also this counter player dsi
along along the back rank for example of
white it's probably stupid move over if
white tries to play again this pawn
there's simply always this idea as a
possibility
and this is not exactly a bad bishop so
I'm not sure I mean was it really
necessary to give give give up the porn
I don't think so I mean in the game
check it's clear that white is advancing
on the on the queenside and black really
am can only employ a certain weight
strategy yeah yes frankly speaking not
much going on black tries to stay active
and exchange points on the Kings side of
possible and using his active bishops
can we continue and it's really not not
much going on as mentioned Jeter Scott
them extra porn but it's not sure if
it's really amounts to much so here's a
critical position in fact then if you
analyze this with the help of the the
computer friend and it gives them a
pretty good line now for black but this
is probably not not realistic to expect
them a human to to play like this I'm
Jesus's Bishop f3 check 95 and Bishop g1
and this looks terribly risky but it
seems to work out be fine takes takes
takes on h2 and b6 it looks at least it
looks very dangerous beep on but if
white moves this bishop there's always
Bishop a7 and in fact this seems to be a
draw something like this
and at the end this phone is falling one
point being that 93 years yeah illegal
in this position okay but this is not
really realistic to to find this what
liquor did is very I was very
understandably we just grabbed b6 and
got into opposite colored bishops but
now it's really it's really hairy maybe
maybe it is losing already the problem
is those pawns are on dark squares so
wyd potentially wins them both so he's
got a potential passed pawn also on the
King side and also those pieces set up a
barrier against the black king so it's
it's possible to maybe even promote one
of those pawns on the queenside in the
game TM missed on one or two occasion is
somewhat tougher defense but it seems
very critical now now this this is
probably a mistake um the computer wants
to play em something else he wants to go
why would you go king here we should be
four and King d5 yep Dwight can take
this this line this is also just winning
for what i thought i would say
it looks very very good for what yeah
I'm not sure that this is really an
improvement yeah I guess I guess black
black is lost him but it's those those
opposite color bishops and games are
notoriously tricky so without investing
really lots of time I'm always cautious
yeah this now is really winning and
later resigned um yeah I don't know
maybe he should have drawn this end game
I mean this end game after he gave up
the pond but I still feel it was
necessary to to even go on go into the
spawn down position and yeah well he
lost unfortunately after winning such a
nice game yesterday against kawana he
went down in this type of position which
really should suit him ok so what games
are left there's also of course cause
this game against even sokoloff so
Carson I'm leading the tournament
together with the island and kayaking if
i'm not mistaken against the tail end
one of the Tanana Sokoloff who really
has a bad tournament and okay causal
place one e-form with the local off you
know that is going to plate you fine if
you're always place in five and we've
got a room sokoloff doesn't play the
balloon though he always place those
more full-blooded lines and again this
art archangel variation that he employed
against them it was kerwin i right way
we lost yeah against karana it cards a
place also with d3 a solid set up
Bishop to g5 and add a quick look in the
database this is already a very rare
position it doesn't look a lot achill at
all but it's not the popular line c3 and
yeah now um the cool off initiates a
rather ambitious plan in the next couple
of moves no not this but let's let's see
yeah he played this he played b form and
this looks a good at first sight because
you you attack the night this the
capture of course looks looks bad then
damaging the pawn structure and this
means that what needs to go back so I'm
you think okay you win you in time by
pushing the nut back but you have a
somewhat awkward piece on a five
yourself and if you look what happens
now because he combined all this with
playing g5 this means that with the
bishop on b7 black has a pretty big hole
on f5 which would be terrible if some
light wood would turn up there and I
don't really like this more information
on the on the queenside I know I'm
probably slightly biased because I play
the Reyes blackened I always prefer
those set up with the bishop on e seven
where it helps to protect my king a bit
and is not exposed on the queenside it
looks active but what is this Bishop
actually doing we see after couple of
moves that white now has got this idea
and once it comes to f5 it's game over
can exchanged and we are just slowly
preparing also deform
and black cannot do much he's got
awkward pieces those pieces really um
don't put pressure on the center and
then their mugs to mostly targets I
don't really like the setup so some
normal moves might have one exchanged v8
so we got root rid of the author of the
heavy pieces and 93 yeah and I still I
think that why this better anyway
because those pieces are simply an
assembly badly positioned also night of
course but what he did now really I
think made things even worse he played
their first this and now this g four
moves and if this is really necessary
that black is in deep trouble now 95 9h
for and night f5 it's really a around
the corner and what is this bond
formation it's simply full of holes yeah
we seem that white gets the Knight to f5
and as mentioned this is basically game
over I don't think this is a defensible
position it took a while but cards and
improved his pieces Rob like really
doesn't have much to do this probably
intends this move I played it to be so
yeah now d 5 this is probably i'm also
not helping opening up at the position
more but it's dreadful to defend the
serve this a really difficult position
against the world number one i think it
even would be difficult to defend
against what number 1000 but number one
is really really
really tough so it opened up and now you
see the King as a terrible crossfire
yeah just open up the position the king
is the target check check yeah black
even manages to to grab the spawn and
here I'm in fact check Carl's had um
even like quicker way to win the game
with Bishop to f5 you play tonight to UM
to d5 which keeps a big advantage but
the other move was was even them even a
bit stronger but it didn't really matter
and widest is winning him in both cases
so I'm Ted Bishop back check you should
neither Queen c6 wasn't somewhat tough
and move but it's lost anyway and here
like resigned simply because he cannot
move we should be to d7 as the big
threat and no way to prevent it if black
plays some Sun move some nothing move
then disqus is coming check and white
wins the Queen and only am latest not
valve with the the extra Queen and the
very bad King position so pretty em
straight forward win for carlton against
the terribly out of form sokoloff he
sokoloff lost is this some pretty poor
game yesterday with white against the
Ronin in the Greenfeld and this really
didn't look good and he didn't recover
at all okay so I now for the for the
last game at this presentation this is
fury against who you farm and giving
place before he played before before in
this tournament and it's not just me
move but he tries to mix first moves
we get get a dragon which is some not a
standard line in who you fonts
repertoire I think she is more from an
idol of was given in and tie off
position player on okay but the dragon
surprisingly g3 was now played rather
tame line against the dragon 96 and 922
this is a black side right side e.m he
wants to keep this piece on the board
and put them knight on d5 sometimes even
the slide you don't he doesn't want to
allow to exchange it so if let's say you
would play this move then black could
consider to simplify a bit by exchanging
Queens it's a it's not terrible for for
white but it should help lack with the
defense to get one power of nights off
so weiter retreats it and she plays like
quite interesting setup now Bishop e7
and Quincy aid so very early setting up
this battery but this sir is quite
annoying from white if white wood castle
now then there's a bishop age three and
this is certainly something that black
is welcoming exchanging off the bishop
because the d7 bishop is notoriously
useless in those positions and th can be
exchanged for this good Bishop on g2
which supports the center and has
potential influence on the long diagonal
in in some cases yeah black can even
dream of age 5 h 4 but this son on a
very good day you manage to do that okay
but canceling is and not what why wants
to do so you played age three I mean
white wants to castle but you don't want
to allow Bishop a tree but h3 now means
yeah how do you cancer now it's always
hanging on
three and in fact them after a couple of
more moves were very normal looking yeah
like introduces this idea try them wants
to prevent would be eight yeah probably
preparing this in the long run roo k 2ya
this of course looks very artificial but
them white wants to get a good off the
long diagonal which can be be tricky
yeah 96 back yeah this term can be an
idea and 95 this is some a typical IDM
in this positions to put this pressure
on the f 69 and actually provoke an
exchange or d5 the ideas after the
exchange okay first this move has played
but what I wasn't getting it ok here it
is especially dreadful because the night
needs to go to the age but the idea is
to open up the South open e file and get
pressure only seven I'm of course white
hasn't castle yet so it's a long way off
but this is a general idea here taking
on d5 is just just crazy you don't want
to go to d8 so this is why she played a
five yeah here you would would think
that why should them demolish the pawn
structure you played c3 though but can
look at this this looks very obvious
hanging at first you think okay this
must be great for white what kind of
confirmation is this but black has very
good counter play sheets can play f5 she
can play b5 and its opposite colored
bishops so both sides play on opposing
color complexes there's simply too much
activity going from black you can cancel
let's say and then do something like
this just for argument's sake those kind
of active lines are possible and yeah
this is this does devon e square so on
this wouldn't net so much but what he
did geary c3 have a look now she breaks
out with b5 and what's now b3 is hanging
how does white react to this he played
the Queen back to the one and now queen
be 80 and suddenly black skirt pressure
against the Big Horn I don't think this
is what white intended to achieve with
these three he covered it and now I'm a
very strong very strong plan by black
takes 95 and we see the point after
let's say castles what give you played
most lateral move she played the very
interesting move a form which it first
them it's not so easy to comprehend what
is this move doing ok let's start with
the easy ones if white would take with a
rock the loop takes be 3s simply great
for black you have this ruckus hanging
and the whole pawn structure here
benefits Black Sea five or so weak
square
black Scott active pieces so it should
be pretty good for relief on white wood
stayed with the rook yeah but what
happens let's say on B takes black can
go here for example and then put
pressure on a 4 D 5 c 3 there's this
move coming and this is a really unlucky
piece it's simply I'm badly positioned
like has quite good compensation here
and the game however we see a four-night
default at first this looks very very
strong i mean this lucas attacked and if
it retreats then white can take or even
play maybe 96 at some point but black
has a very strong answer she just took
hun be 39 takes and lightsey for very
strong like has sacrificed the holbrook
for the moment but now this ruckus
attacked and it's not protected and this
night had also attacked if white would
retreat the rock now he played this move
funny but if white would retreat the
Rope let's say okay one then black
simply captures here and that has this
fantastic vporn which is supported by
the night and like has pretty much
winning advantage here also note that
the support is also coming so I'm yeah
great for for black so this is like
giving played the desperado move 95 you
don't want to allow flag to caption on
b3 to get the passport yeah okay you
need to take this
and now I will return but blacks got the
great game now this ship is hanging this
is hanging legs got all the activity and
da porn we see that she just took it
yeah trying to oops not there activate
the night good try get rid of the the
bishops but like some very active nom
will be too and in this position own
death and another funny case of we have
the computer wants to play a move that
probably no human would come up with she
am now played a 3 which according to the
computer and by mathematical standard so
to say is a mistake but what the
computer wants to play is really
something that as mentioned no human
would would come up with the computer
recommends here Luke v8 yeah what what
about this right yeah white can take and
then the computer wants to grab here and
says that yeah black is completely
winning still I believe that human
player would be very reluctant to get
into this right moves the Queen and
there's some ideas on g7 I don't know
it's very unnatural to play like this
with little time on the clock what she
did is a good practical decision to pin
a 3 attacking the Queen and white needs
to take and now black and take here she
couldn't do this immediately because the
Queen was saying so you need to distract
widescreen and after this we have a
simplified position now where black has
an extra porn the extra see porn and
simply enjoy some distant advantage with
no
losing chances whatsoever so black can
simply press for a win here with no risk
and this is some it is probably winning
but it done it also entails no risk at
all we see that some repetition to gain
some time and now we've got G against
upon exchange and now it's a pure frizzy
pawn yeah this intense Queen g7 to get
rid of the blockade on c3 and he'll give
reham decided to yeah that he doesn't
want to fight the sea porn and he sacked
the exchange yeah covering six and yeah
what what is this position yeah I think
it should be it should be a win for
black but it's not not a trivial win
what surprised me a bit is that he
actually allowed with Queenie form the
the Queen trade call think this is
definitely winning it's it's a trickier
than you first might think because there
are some aspects of the position that
done are not so great like Scott te
ponen only six this is slightly weak and
what is blacks winning plan one winning
plan would be to go all the way to the
airport and the tickets on the second
rank and this is basically almost the
only plan that black has let's see what
happens y term just move the f chan chan
starter not much happening up to a
certain point check
check like managed to get optimum
activity but here it is now difficult to
make any progress how would you make any
progress this Bishop stays on the long
diagonal and this King always keeps a g3
protected and there's something like a
wall here so that the King cannot enter
how should black proceed in fact you
played this very nicely starting with
age 6 preparing g5 and this break
actually guarantees that black will get
a free porn this is exactly what
happened here why I decided to play with
the age pawning up with the G pony could
also take on 1g5 after which black gets
it back this way and then pushes the
pawn which at the end will promote
together with the rook or with the rook
support so King f3 and right now it's
got the H porn as the counter play but
it's simply not enough check now the
pawn is moving forward this is funny but
ok we still have the upon I didn't say
it's completely winning White has no
alternative just King moves as of course
the bishop needs to stay to cover the
pond and here in fact white needs to
give it up yeah this is important can
how to take care of course because this
check
so this is ye too and what is it's
important to note that in fact this this
happened in the game that this is a
winning end game and not the drawn end
game of course I'm rook against bishop
is a draw in general and the important
point is that White's King needs to
reach the opposite colored corner so
King on a one Bishop on b1 this would be
a draw but the problem is it is not on a
one and what never will get there and in
this position in fact um it terminates I
think even a false mate because this
Bishop is getting lost is simply am you
would simply get trapped on the back
rank so something like this the Sun is
the problem and if you go somewhere else
check and simply this kind of tab will
move right you win the bishop next
movement made a couple of moves later in
the game here played this cheese slaw
and after this rook check resigned it
would simply continue like this gaining
a tempo the shoot moves and then
somewhere here attacking the bishop and
threatening the checkmate and like maids
are wins the bishop so the first win
form the form of women world champion
who you found in this tournament beating
geary with black in a pretty good game I
think it's some pretty pre well played
she really outplayed him here in the
middle middle game and I feel really a
good for her that she managed to win a
game in this really really tough field
she really if you look at those little
interview snippets that the website is
having they always do the slow kind of
interviews after the game
just like a minute or two minutes
sometimes she still seemed very very um
yeah in very good spirits even after all
those losses and it's good to see him
that she that she managed to win a game
alright i hope you enjoyed it it had
been it's been a long video again but i
think it's really um yeah good chest
content it's not not too many um dial
drawers or quick draws today even some
long-ish end games which you could
analyze even a deeper but i already am
on close to 70 minutes i hope you
enjoyed it I'll be back tomorrow with
the next round bye